et pour bruno droz qui est orient est
maître de conférences à l'inalco et la
libération des manifestants ne va pas
redorer l'image du gouvernement écoute
elle le problème c'est qu'évidemment ici
ils ont été assez visiblement maltraité
pendant leur séjour en prison
ce qui rajoute évidemment à la colère
donc évidemment les libérer c'est une
bonne chose mais en même temps bien sûr
ce qu'il raconte de ce qu'ils ont vécu
n'aide pas beaucoup à redorer le blason
s'il se retire du pouvoir
ce qui est assez assez notable c'est que
une grande partie de la population bien
nourrie fiennes qui n'aimait pas
beaucoup le drapeau des nationalistes
biélorusses hien aujourd'hui se
retranche derrière ce drapeau et on ne
voit plus le drapeau officiel dans les
manifestations ce qui ce qui doit être
prise en compte et qui montre quand même
un changement d'une partie notable de
l'opinion